um so this new project uh because I feel
like album Number One you get the Grammy
nomination I actually liked your second
album more thank you um you know it's
because I thought you said personal and
I just thought it was
I thought it was more focused
I agree I agree it was more my second
album was more
from um
it was more polished like the lyricisms
was better no for songwriting was better
the the the construction of the album
like the sequencing of it was better I
think it didn't connect at the level
that I wanted to because it wasn't as
transparent and vulnerable that's just
my opinion so this album
we don't even know what's going to be on
the album yeah we don't know we ain't
including me you're gonna be on the
album I sure hope so that'd be a weird
Flex obviously Metro boom I ain't even
on my own album I got everybody yeah
that ain't it uh I need my plug
like you said earlier you're pretty much
just like yo I'm doing what's true to me
at this moment and whoever it connects
to is who it's for absolutely do you
give a [__] though about because when
you come out the gate with a Grammy
nomination that's a pretty wild [__]
thing to do no for sure it's only like
eight of us who like debut like debut
album yeah yeah that's got to be a gift
and a curse too because now you're
looked at in a certain light where it's
like well if you came first time got the
Grammy nomination what you're gonna do
with this next one yeah do you let that
pressure get to you or do you think
about it and let it psych you out at all
nah bro because I never I I was never
like the hottest [__] out when I first
came out it's always with me it's just
been like
so it's been I don't know if there's a
weird noise but um whatever I get it but
it's kind of just been steps after step
but bro I've only been in the game
it'll be four years since my first album
five years since I like people started
to know my name and know my music and
[__] and um so five years since Kung Fu
came out it'll be five years in July
what year did I already see so I've
already seen so many artists just come
and go within this yeah small five it'll
be the artist that was the hottest and
I'm not saying no names because this
respect as long as they're able to feed
their families change their own family
lives it's love they still won they
still win this rap game is the lottery
so any level of success you could you
could achieve [__] is better than
99.9 of the rapper pool absolutely for
sure so um I said I don't have seen so
many artists come and go so I know for a
fact I'll be able to make music at the
highest level for the next 20 years and
still be able to make a great living for
the next 20 years off music I'm not
worried about that it's just about how
high am I going to take you how high can
I take this [__] and every year I've
been leveling up and I've been able to
see this literally from my first tour I
did 500 camera rooms my second tour I
did a thousand cabins my last two I did
two thousand cabins you know and that's
where I kind of based my successful
first week these are real humans bro
that's a real fan because they had to
leave their house get a babysitter maybe
buy a ticket right [__] get dropped
off by their parents get dropped call
The Uber take a shower put on some fresh
[__] then wait in line and no matter
what the weather or not put on some
fresh [__] exactly or not showers to see
you do what you love you know what I'm
saying versus like a number that can be
skewed or falsified yeah a lot of these
[__] streams are fake
a lot of them I mean I would venture to
say
sorry Dwight
99.9 percent of these major label
[__] artists there's some sort of
[__] little tick on the [__]
numbers going on yeah I wouldn't doubt
it bro and the thing is
it's like I was saying like I don't it
don't bother me and I'm not just saying
that because some [__] does bother me
I'm a human [__] being bro I got
feelings and emotion but it doesn't
bother me with this because I'm seeing
real life wins when I'm doing a sold out
tour you know what I'm saying that's all
and that's the that's that's the real
[__] that matters so even when like
you're selling merch and you're you know
people are supporting you with their
where they're that's the [__] that
differentiates somebody who can catch a
record catch a moment and then somebody
who can have longevity and pay their
bills and you know and open up a club
and turn down million dollar deals from
The Gap absolutely never was a gap guy
myself I didn't I didn't even know that
it didn't even make it it didn't even
make it back to me you should yell at
him for that no that's cool I'd like to
know if the Gap was knocking yeah I
never knew that honestly
what's up Diego tell them about the Gap
that never came across my table really
never I didn't know but I say that to
say that's the stuff that don't even
come to me that you know what I'm saying
that's what I said it to say like I say
no to a lot of [__] bro I just like to
do what I'm passionate about what's on
brand for me as a human being and what I
love to do things I'm passionate about
things I love so